a childlike AI savior or Humanity's
destruction the Creator asks a lot of
questions and not all of them are
clearcut here's how the ending of the
Creator affects the film's world
spoilers ahead before we get to the
finale of The Creator let's do a quick
recap the East and West are locked in a
vicious War over AI after being
undercover in an Eastern resistance Army
lead character Joshua heads back to the
east for a new mission to help American
forces find a new AI project from a
mysterious Guru known as NADA when his
team arrives at lab holding the coveted
AI he finds that it's actually a
simulant a human-looking robot with AI
programming that's a child Joshua
believes that this child named Alfie can
lead him to his former wife Maya so he
takes Alfie on a journey to find her in
the old Rebellion he once betrayed along
the way Joshua learns that Maya is
actually near Ma and that the nuclear
bomb that kicked off this whole war
against AI was actually due to human
error it also turns out that Alfie was
created to destroy the West super weapon
Nomad but only to achieve peace since
the AI don't really want to kill the
human
as her journey continues Joshua becomes
closer to Alfie due to Maya's love and
creating Alfie and her being molded
after Joshua and Maya's child
unfortunately by the time Joshua and
Alie reach Maya she's in a coma and they
can now only cut her life support to set
her free they do so but are captured by
American forces and now must enact a new
plan to destroy the Nomad after
reuniting and escaping American forces
Joshua and Alfie Now find themselves
looking to get onto a ship to a moon
Colony once on board Alfie uses her
technology controlling abilities to
Pilot the ship towards the orbiting
Nomad which is priming missiles to fire
at the remaining resistance bases their
arrival on The Nomad spins everything
into chaos though as Joshua is forced to
go out into open space to put a bomb on
the nomad's missiles and Alfie must make
a Mad Dash to the control room while
there are tough obstacles they're forced
to overcome their plan ultimately works
and they're able to cause a chain
reaction explosion on The Nomad
unfortunately their escape plans are
upended by the interference of the
American government and Joshua is forced
to stay behind while Alfie escapes via
an escape pod they share one last last
tearful interaction that sees them
Express their love for one another and
Joshua tells Alfie that he now gets to
go to heaven because of their journey
together although this would seem like a
sad ending for this unlikely parrying it
ends up being joyous Joshua is allowed
one last goodbye to Maya since Alfie put
her brain data into a simulant that
looked like her and the two embrac
before being consumed by the explosion
Alfie is seen celebrating with the
revolutionaries and now knows her vision
of Peace can be
achieved one of the big overarching
themes of the Creator is the impact in
people's perceptions of a ey while it
was initially seen as a tool to help
humans do menial tasks or even expand
our own forms of entertainment to a
degree it eventually became something
you either loved or loathed after the
unprovoked dropping of a nuclear bomb
over Los Angeles occurred and killed
thousands the world became divided into
two ideologies either that AI could live
alongside people peacefully or that it
was going to make Humanity extinct this
debate is a huge part of Joshua's
personal Arc as he starts to see the AI
entities around him in the same vein as
Maya that they're truly Almost Human
this this debate will be something that
real people will continue to have and
delve deeper into as AI develops even
further in the real world AI has gotten
better and better and it feels like
we're at that Tipping Point now the
Creator instantly Taps into these
growing fears and concerns that many
have about Ai and it's certainly
becoming a bigger conversation as we see
more AI programs being developed even
the recent wga and sag after strikes
have been heavily influenced by the
growing use of AI and its effects on
people's livelihoods the Creator hits
right at the heart of where AI stands in
our society and makes us question
whether we'll see it as an enemy or Ally
as we evolve with Alfie and Joshua
destroying Nomad the entire tide of the
war has changed throughout the war The
Nomad was a key way the West hoped to
Pummel the Eastern resistance since they
didn't have to get many of their troops
involved Nomad could fire missiles from
the high atmosphere that could easily
cause massive destruction to rebel bases
the only thing keeping the west from
outright defeating the East and killing
their AI was Alfie since she has the
power to control any technology around
her including the Nomad execute her or
we go extinct so when Alfie and Joshua
finally Blow The Nomad to smithin it
essentially ensures the East the ability
to win and for AI to live freely Maya's
vision for Alfie to lead the AI to their
freedom and create peace around the
world is now achievable we may never
know what exactly happens as a result of
the war but the destruction of nomad
certainly works in the favor of the East
and Alfie Joshua and Maya could easily
be seen as tide Turners who allowed
peace between Ai and humans to prosper
in this world one of the more
eye-opening moments of the Creator is
when Joshua learns what really caused
the nuclear bomb to drop on La while the
common belief is that an AI program
dropped the bomb without cause it was
actually an error in the programming
codes caused by humans given that the AI
and simulants have been created by
humans as well it seems like the west
and other human opposers should really
be pointing the fingers set themselves
after all AI wouldn't exist without
humans creating it instead of
questioning why we decide to create AI
in the first place or have
self-reflective moments of change
Humanity specifically the West decided
to put the blame squarely on AI and set
out on a quest to destroy it that left
the world hanging in the balance so
perhaps director Gareth Edwards is
trying to create a cautionary message
showing that we need to take
accountability for our actions if we
want to make things better rather than
finding something or someone to take the
fall although most of the American
soldiers and government figures hate AI
due to past Devastation lingering fears
or personal trauma there's a moment late
in the film that highlights her
hypocrisy when Alfie is roaming The
Nomad she eventually gets into a room
where various AI simulants can be seen
standing around and covered in white
fabric it looks like an AI testing lab
and some of the subjects even look like
Maya so even though there's this
unbridled hatred toward Ai and plans for
Destruction it seems like America is
still toying around with the concept the
hypocrisy couldn't be clearer it's even
worse that Alfie found all of this on
The Nomad the weapon designed to wipe
out the AI simulants in the Eastern
resistance in reality this probably
shows that the West plans were never to
completely wipe out AI rather they
wanted to wipe out what the East had and
then restart their own AI efforts with
no opposition the film being a globe
spanning War between the West and East
isn't by accident and it's likely
inspired by the current tensions we have
globally it's no secret that there's
some ideological conflicts between the
West namely the US and Western European
countries and the East with countries
like Russia China and North Korea being
major standouts these visions of
communism versus democracy as well as
paranoia surrounding military power and
signs of aggression are as timely as it
gets the Creator certainly plays on
those fears by having the focal point of
its West versus East conflict be Ai and
the fears of what it can do if AI
technology continues to develop at a
rapid Pace the fears of the film could
easily start to be seen as a reflection
of the already real tensions we're
feeling it's not to say the film is
establishing some sort of fear-mongering
or that it's predicting some sort of
future conflict it's just a movie after
all but it's ties to the tense
atmosphere between Western and Eastern
Nations shouldn't be lost on audiences
the future's never looked better
although the film doesn't delve too deep
into the impact of the nuke being
dropped into LA or the impact of the
long years of war Humanity has endured
there are are some aspects that show the
ripples of trauma these events have
caused when Joshua is cleaning the
remaining Rubble in La it's hard not to
feel your heart sink even when Joshua is
roaming through the East territories
it's easy to feel how this war is
ravaged and ripped apart people's
livelihood forcing them to constantly
live in fear the Creator shows the
impact of global war and is another
instance of the film acting as a visual
warning of what we're currently dealing
with there are emotional scars and
irreversible destruction that all
stemmed from these conflicts and it's a
swift reminder of how war and tragedy
have wide ripples that affect everyone
even though it's not on the battlefield
one of the more interesting aspects to
Joshua and alie's perspective together
and the ending of their journey in the
East is their perception of Heaven at
first Joshua gives Alfie the standard
definition of Heaven are you going to
heaven
no you got to be a good person to go to
heaven his description surprisingly
Comforts Alfie since she's not a person
and she believes that Joshua isn't good
however Alfie and Joshua end up reaching
heaven on Earth which is where Maya is
resting and acts as a peaceful place for
simulants AI and people people to
coexist peacefully it's a setting that
not only has interesting religious
undertones with his Buddhist inspiration
but also Alters Joshua and Alfie's
perspective on how Heaven could be
achieved this changes their beliefs
about heaven being some Fantastical
place in the sky good people go to when
they die and they understand that a good
place can be achieved on Earth Maya's
vision for Alfie to create a more
peaceful world can be their real life
heaven and by the end of the film that's
exactly what's set in motion although
Maya and Joshua can't join her in this
world their efforts and assistance in
her journey have helped her build this
new heaven on Earth and embodying the
new meaning of the word she and Joshua
come to understand now for the
all-important question that needs to be
asked is there a potential for a sequel
for the Creator to be made in terms of
the story the film ends on a conclusive
note but it does have potential to
continue the next film could easily see
Alfie lead the resistance to completely
win the war or further explore the world
of Peace she's trying to build on her
own now obviously the film's performance
at the box office will heavily indicate
if a sequel really comes to light but it
seems like at least as far as director
Gareth Edwards is concerned the Creator
will stand alone in an interview with
Screen Rant Edwards said that he had no
plans at the moment to pen a sequel and
is more than satisfied by the film's
conclusive ending he said I just want it
to be the self-contained thing if
someone ever came up and said we want a
sequel that'd be a really good problem
to have but it is not the plan but since
these decisions aren't always in the
hands of well the creators the MOX
office Hall will probably dictate
whether audiences see more of this world
or
[Music]
not